hey I gotta start again man I feel bad
we're gonna start right off by killing
these sons of [ __ ] the hell alright
alright here we go
I don't like this
alright listen I'm oh [ __ ] that better
run god I hate that thing alright
goddamn alright there we go
shoot that son of a [ __ ] it's kind of
sexy I mean I wanna hug him not really
alright I don't know what I'm gonna
start shooting with the shotgun though
you subscribe oh [ __ ]
all right let's shoot is [ __ ] then
is it dad I don't have a map
shotgun time chuckling time baby
all right let's do like the dignified
tale oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] here we go
you gotta wait for it
oh that is nasty
god damn that a fate ah uh a guy how are
you doing here girl what's up girl
where is she is that our wife maybe what
is she doing today
it's the generator room all right huh
what was that I don't know
oh [ __ ] well then how was that good in
the hell wouldn't heaven
alright I don't know what I am but let's
pick this the boiler room what is going
on I don't know Harry but I think the
business I run I think I'll use that
copyright let's take this Oh goddamn key
huh alright that's pretty cool so this
is the valves I turn huh I guess I get
alright let's head out new adventures
ah it's kind of nice now that's not so
bad
out of this [ __ ] school that's for
sure and Josh Bell is ringing the bell
I think it's defano what is this Belkin
search
alright ready call let's go to the
church then bris
I took a little break if you look on the
map down in the left where I am right
now this is where you go to the other
place cuz all the [ __ ] barriers are
blocked goddamnit more dinosaurs uh-oh
it's doggies oh oh come on don't die now
Larry or whatever Harry whatever alright
we can go ahead oh this game just makes
me sweat I just want a head alright can
we go in here that was what the key
gordon key was for does it say kid
Gordon Street or some [ __ ] like that
[ __ ] me I don't give a [ __ ] handgun
hello I'll Lake nice to say yo hair up
what is this
someone put tables for me that's right
let's do a save here [ __ ] yes we'll see
Gordon Gordon Freeman sigh you do you 11
hunter garden did we find anything else
in here garden quite alright God go I
tried quite right hahaha look at that TV
it looks quite old actually
alright Oh Harry watch yourself now
running it always alright let's go to
the [ __ ] clock house holy [ __ ] Silent
Hill is not a nice game when it comes to
telling you where the [ __ ] to go I think
we need to go solve and then through
that tiny little hallway this wait what
do I read over here
chainsaws out bright chainsaw that's
where we go and Rose doesn't sound that
good desert I don't think it leaves but
that is my opinion
maybe you're a chain side lover you are
you are you I just call your head
dinosaur shut up
look at that slalom look at this slalom
feeding my goes left if I go right good
my go loud bang all right at it's scars
that is not slalom whatever all right we
need to go in this creep all the way
[ __ ] off dinosaur see this skills this
is how I dodge bullies like yeah I got
that yeah oh hang on give me that I need
no sorry don't make me break down no
how's my health come on
dinosaur don't make me kill you alright
hey have you heard [ __ ] off yeah out
about that look at my health not some
dinosaur and get down for this [ __ ]
[ __ ] it I'm running I guess my slalom
was overrating at least grab hang onion
bullets all right
and we need to go here I think and this
should be just up ahead yep
if this road is crossed I'm gonna cross
your nipples
I gotta cross them right up not that I'm
gonna cross y'all nipple ride up girl I
don't even know what that means but
here's Belkin Church girl let's go
inside and see what we can find look at
that church where's the entrance though
the skies and tonsure it's not any
language at all oh it's just [ __ ]
open oh [ __ ]
this day says I'm sorry Jay says
while in heavens
were you ringing that Bell I've been
expecting you
it was foretold by Jai romance [ __ ]
this Jai romantic what are you talking
about yeah what are you talking about I
knew you'd come the zoo nipples have a
radar right
it's my [ __ ] daughter but girl you're
talking about Cheryl I see everything do
you see my penis you know something tell
me that's weird
stay back you really did this might be
gained from floundering about it random
I like her English you must follow the
path all right
the path of the Hermit concealed by
flowers okay I don't understand you what
what are you talking about
Leigh are you on drugs I think she's
under nice tie flowers a major piece it
can break through the walls of darkness
okay and counteract the wrath of the
underworld whatever you say lady
whatever you say help you knifed Ida
make haste to the hospital before it's
too late I don't want to go to a
hospital no public places please
wait don't go yet wait don't go
you haven't seen my penis yet come on
let's both
poor Larry alright what about Jesus we
got the Flores I guess I'll take it and
the key to the hospital drawbridge
there's a drawbridge Jace's I'm sorry I
took this just kidding I'm not hahaha
oh hello what is this okay I guess I'll
say they owe on the guard on the church
very well I tried quite right all right
why do we have I think I'll end it
subsidy all right we need to go to the
hospital this is gonna take a while I'm
sure I don't even know where the
hospital is
oh there's a drawbridge over that bridge
control room I'm sure we have to go
there I didn't take me long at all look
at this slalom ah good it's this don't
in rock my slalom ahh girl look at that
slalom no no parking anytime girl look
at that Sanne girl looking at now the
dogs don't want to rhyme and when I walk
in the street this is what I see
dinosaurs and dogs I had taken at me I
got bullets in my pants penis and my
pants and I ain't afraid I shot one I'm
playing Silent Hill and you know what
dude that's pretty good but [ __ ] are
your dough and underneath that don't do
anything all right the control and let's
check what we can find in the
hi penny hey miss J that I got a
magazine for you Oh night
oh yeah get read though ah job ha
sorry as for being beautiful now what
are we doing with this place huh
what did we do with you give it that yep
I'll take it so we need to draw the
bridge stop set it it's a keyhole
well [ __ ] put it in man Jesus Christ
do I really have to do that
the machineries running do you want to
press the switch
oh hi my dad I know okay
I didn't sound that good ah top
all right enough wasting time Harry
I guess what I don't even know what I
just dead
what did I do
my leaving sample
I don't have a map for that play oh no I
don't like that
I I want Matt be what does it say 35
faster oh no oh no where do I go
whatever fine George come at me
dinosaurs ah no stop
she could have told him
number ones forget T how does it help me
now police car - police car monkey [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] me
trait I thought it was a I thought it
was a magazine maze - I was trying to
help me all along
instead I hit him I feel like such a bad
person
and I never opened the bridge did I all
right we got to do that [ __ ] I'll see
you in a second why is the machine still
running and she just
I don't even know I don't even know I
don't bring a bow what are we gonna do
what am I gonna do I don't
all right let's see here we're good
going to the hospital
so that was [ __ ] easy I'm an idiot
this game is not like today's game I
tell you as much in a normal game today
the game would have been like wait I
shouldn't go without my map and then I
would be like wait did I forget the map
kind of running around like an idiot
looking for a map but hey I'm an idiot
so it's okay let's just go to the
[ __ ] hospital get our daughter back
did you do today to get dick get bigger
good I don't know what from the back
where the hell is entrance this is the
hospital isn't it ain't it
thank you the hospital dinosaur I don't
have time for you how the hell did we
get in oh I don't like this I really
oh please don't be monkeys ah [ __ ]
doggies dogs thugs thugs eggs like that
calm the [ __ ] down calm the [ __ ] down
calm the [ __ ] down that's it I'll thank
God I made it alright I'm gonna get it
right I gotta get my gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna yeah
alright it's monkey shooting time
hello oh [ __ ] me what is that oh so it
begins huh
let's go well it's gotta be a lot of
health stuff here I love later nice
pixels there nice
what another cutscene so many of them
now
what is that
as a man with a good no all right I'm
gonna end here breath I can fit it if
you alright
subscribe kind of grid they down them
let me I feel like an [ __ ]
no no wait change my vibe not die